today we're going to look at one of my
favorite works of servant kierkegaard
great christian existentialist uh author
philosopher theologian of the 19th
century uh the philosophical fragments a
work that is not
as often read or commented upon as a
fear of trembling or the sickness unto
death
or even repetition
but is very rich it's very dense there's
a lot going on there and these themes
are
very closely connected with other themes
that
kierkegaard is concerned with
and i've got some questions up here but
before we get to those i want to talk
about another question that i think
probably
puts everything that kierkegaard does
into
the best perspective
you can say that kierkegaard's
work
in general
you know central motivation
is grappling with the question
does christianity make a difference
not just does believing
in
christian doctrines lead one to do
things differently
in one's life a sort of you know
pragmatic appeal
not just in the sense of does one have a
different metaphysics a different
ontology a different ethics thereby
but in a deeper sense
does it make a difference
that
christianity is there and has to be
grappled with
as something that
presents a
coherent
not only way of thinking but
a way of life one yet however that
doesn't claim to have all the answers
although some churches may sometimes
claim to have all the answers and
actually most of them don't if you
actually read their their writings
carefully
christianity by itself is for kikigaard
something less of a
system of thought or system of rules and
something more like
a journey something that one embarks
upon this doesn't mean that it all
becomes very loosely goosey and you know
make it what you like
but rather he's focused on the
experiential existential
even effective or passionate elements of
it
now this book itself is written by uh
you know
you know it's a
sort of pseudonymous
work again
and
this book is written from a
philosophical perspective and what he's
trying to do that
is grapple with
what would christianity
mean he's sort of
approaching it almost from the outside
trying to say what would the
implications be
for
philosophical thought
would philosophy be able to assimilate
that
assimilate this
new experience or being or relationship
or even consciousness of what oneself is
so this brings us to these questions
what is the human condition
what is our state
and kirker great very clearly associates
that in this work with another question
how do we learn
what are we learning
if you think about it
human life you know begins at birth
ends at least in certain respects that
death and then everything in between
is in some respect a matter of learning
you know the infant comes into the world
and has to learn a lot of different
things many people make it all the way
to the end without learning some of the
things that they would like to have have
come across would like to have
understood
there are many people who live their
entire lives in some sort of dark night
you might say whether
of air whether
you know a clash within themselves of
their desires passions
there's all sorts of
modes of learning
and
before we actually go into talking about
those i want to you might say begin at
the end what we're going to cover today
here is chapter 1 and chapter 2.
i would like to start by
looking at the very last things that
the author says
he's sketching out a project
and both times he's apologizing at the
end of the chapter which i find really
interesting
he says there you have my project this
is
chapter one but i think i hear someone
say this is the most ridiculous of all
projects or rather you are of all
projectors of hypotheses the most
ridiculous for even when a man propounds
something nonsensical
this could be nonsensical it may still
remain true that it's he who's
propounded it
but you behave like lazaro and takes
money for exhibiting premises open to
everybody's inspection
you are like a man the man who collected
a fee for exhibiting a ram in the
afternoon but in the
foreign field
kierkegaard is admitting here that what
he's saying is not something radically
new
that he's
exploring that he's restating something
that all of us have the opportunity
even without any sort of commitment to
christian faith but i have to stress
this
this is not a committed work
this is not a work of dogmatic theology
this is a work sort of exploring the
implications of christianity from the
outside through philosophy seeing what
what christianity would flood into or
would it pose upon or would would offer
to philosophy
and you could say well you know it's out
there
philosophy is out there it's all free
um
why should we even say
pay for this book
that's what he's admitting to
he's saying
i can't say that what i'm saying is
actually radically new i can't take any
any real credit for him i'm just saying
i'm just bringing it up because it is
something worth talking about he is a
great example he says
everybody knows that gunpowder was
invented centuries ago and it would be
ridiculous for me to pretend to be the
inventor
but it would it would be equally
ridiculous of me to assume that somebody
that wouldn't be equally ridiculous of
me to assume that somebody was the
inventor i'm going to assume somebody
came up with this and here he has a
really interesting twist
and again this is one of the things i
love about kierkegaard
kierkegaard does not try to compel you
kierkegaard
invites you to sort of inhabit a
perspective which he sets out for you
and then he says what do you think about
this here's what i think about it but
i'm not going to force you
why don't you tell me what what you
think what you say how it strikes you
and then he lays out various
possibilities that could strike you this
way i could strike you this way
so he says now i'm going to be so polite
as to assume that you are the author of
my project
greater blindness than this you can
scarcely ask or if you deny this
will you deny that someone is the author
that is to say some human being
so he says
fine
this is something that anybody can think
of anybody could come across how about
you
how about you the reader
how about you and your own existential
condition i'm not going to pretend to
occupy the same place and perspective
that you do but insofar as there is a
human condition
you're just as well
suited to talk about it and to think
about it as i am as a matter of fact why
shouldn't you
maybe you're missing out on something if
you don't
at the very end of chapter 2
he says something kind of similar
he's he's now sketched out what he
called a poem
a
really
it's more like a platonic mythos
plato
who kierkegaard has great respect for
will at certain points in his dialogues
um
after they've been doing some
dialectical argument some back and forth
you know
some clash of perspectives some some
making the case to each other
every once in a while socrates will tell
a story
he'll bring up a legend or a bin and
invariably plato is putting his own take
on this
and
socrates will say something like well
i've heard this story couldn't it be
like this and then you'll tell the story
kierkegaard is doing that with
christianity
he's doing that in this champion the
second chapter
with the figure of christ
as the servant
as the one who comes to redeem but not
by you know just imposing power or
sucking everybody in but by suffering by
undergoing by taking on everything that
humanity could could throw at him and by
you know
even actually dying i wouldn't even say
just withstanding all of it
dying encountering death itself
so he calls us a poem
and he says this poem of yours is the
most wretched piece of plagiarism ever
perpetuated for it's neither more nor
less than what every child knows
i suppose i was blushed with shame to
hear myself call the
but why the most wretched
every poet who steals steals from other
some other poet and in so far we are all
equally wretched indeed my own theft is
perhaps less harmful since it's more
readily discovered and he's saying
basically here
i'm not making up a new story
the story's out there i'm just sort of
bringing it up
and you know shedding a little you know
new light from different angles on it it
would be as if somebody was to tell the
story of
the encounter of the disciples with with
a disguise christ on the way to emmaus
and put it into you know contemporary
things so they're driving a van instead
is that
plagiarism
uh
no it's not plagiarism because you're
retelling the the same story and you're
keeping the same basic traits if it is
indeed the same story and that's what
kierkegaard is doing with this and again
he's saying
i'm not trying to like derive
christianity out of my own head i'm not
trying to claim that i have any radical
new insights about it all i'm doing is
re-exploring it
and all i'm doing is like looking at how
philosophy might be connected with it
what its implications would be
so he says
is there then no poet although there is
a poem
or is this poem perhaps like a proverb
for which no author can be assigned
because it is if it owed its existence
to humanity at large
maybe i robbed the whole human race
if this is the case
then mankind must be the author but
wouldn't this be a strange conclusion
for if mankind were the author of this
poem this would have to be expressed by
considering every individually equally
close of the authorship
there is something to be taught
there is something there is progress to
be made so
we often think of these these stories we
often think of these
these fundamental narratives that
can very easily become just part of our
culture
and become estranged from religious
belief religious practice religious
communities
as being a kind of common heritage that
we all own
but
here's something really interesting
kierkegaard doesn't explore this but i
think that you can see this in
discussions of narrative
you really only get out of the story of
what you're willing to put into it
so if you're willing to study it
if you're willing to explore it
if you're willing to try to not only put
yourself into identification with the
characters but think about its
implications for you
how it would play out in your
relationships in the world that you
inhabit
then you get a lot more out of the story
than somebody who's very just passively
consuming it
it's only when you
you might say take a story apart by its
nuts and bolts and then try to put it
back together sometimes you have things
left over if you do that
then you really see what makes it work
and what's going on
and if the story is not just a story
about purely external things
but it's actually a story that from the
beginning has been about ourselves
who we are and that's the kind of
stories that plato told and that's the
kind of stories that we see
in certain parts at least of the
scriptures
that kierkegaard is implicitly referring
to
so that's a good launching point right
there we're talking about this question
how do we learn what is education
kierkegaard only talks about
two basic kinds of teaching and teachers
in this book
but i really want to contrast
this against two other
modes of education and so there is
the teacher who is
socrates
and then there will be the
teacher who is
god
and they actually
want to be very specific
this is a christian view it's an
incarnate god
is a god who
takes on
humanity not just a human semblance but
humanity
all the way down
all the way
to his very nature
book places itself into the human
condition
and he's going to be exploring what's
the difference between these two why
does he only talk about these two
well because he
conceives of socrates as
sort of
being
but not just being
but also exemplifying as playing out as
showing us in plato's dialogue so plato
is involved here as well
the highest potential
the highest activity
for
human beings acting in a
natural way disconnected from
the supernatural order or you know
religious
or you might think of it in a different
way humanity on its own
humanity by itself
socrates for kierkegaard represents the
pinnacle
this is as good as it gets a really
interesting thing to say because he's
constantly criticizing
the people of his own time for assuming
that philosophy has made so much
progress or you know human insight into
the human condition insight into what is
education insight into what is most
valuable has made a lot of progress
since the time of socrates
and plato as well kierkegaard thinks
that that's not the case
so hegel is great kierkegaard you know
likes hale in some respects he actually
studied with schelling another great
german philosopher at the time but he
thinks that the best they could make it
to is this level
and all the new shapes
of philosophy
wind up
either replicating this or they might go
on to something else but let's think
about two
other ways of considering education
teaching learning
that he doesn't talk about per se but
would be great to contrast with this
and i'm not going to use names here
instead
i'm going to talk about functions the
way education works
one way in which we often tend to think
about education
and it's a defaced way it's an incorrect
way it's it captures something that is
important in education but
is not the be-all and end-all and when
it's turned into that it screws
everything up
education is not merely transferring
information transferring information is
part of it
but
you know
simply holding this book in your hand or
running your eyes over it or memorizing
the lines
or you know even the order of the words
is not yet to know kierkegaard and to
understand the thoughts that he had to
say nor even would be giving a summary
of you know sort of an abstract of all
the different things that are said and
all their connections with each other
that can be expressed as information
that can be reduced to information
what's missing there
is something that socrates provided
which is the
the human aspect
my knowledge
is actually
my knowledge
and it's not just knowledge of things
that i have stuck in my head
it's knowledge of myself in relation to
those things
that's a really important thing that
often gets left out by educators
sometimes it gets trivialized too you
know we feel like well everybody gives
their opinion in class now we're
realizing this human aspect
that's not the case that's not getting
to socrates level yet just merely having
an opinion or feelings about things is
not yet
going beyond a different kind of
information instead of you know hard
information it's loosely goosey feeling
information
this is more about some sort of
coherence
developing a
perspective
that can jive in knowledge in action in
orientation in relationships if you look
at what socrates did he lived a life
and he taught people a different kind of
life he didn't just teach them
here's some knowledge for you or here's
a philosophy or something like that
did plato for that matter he taught a
way of living a way of orienting oneself
a way of choosing
in it the moral and the intellectual are
intimately intertwined
another way
another type of
way of thinking about learning teaching
and all of that that would be the analog
over here on this side of transferring
information
would be
what has been often called a theology of
kind of extrinsicism meaning
things are only coming from the outside
you would go beyond the merely
human the natural
what we can access on our own by use of
the reason that we've been endowed with
being created as those sorts of
beings rational beings
you you can go beyond it in several ways
one is god can can actually reveal
something and this is you know being
taken seriously as a philosophical
possibility in the philosophical
fragments
in part because christianity makes that
claim actually so does judaism so does
islam
every one of the great religious
traditions in so far as it's made an
impact on philosophy
one of the ways in which it did make an
impact on philosophy was by supplying
new ideas
supplying clarification on certain
issues by turning their attention to
looking at some some
questions
some concepts that hadn't really been
worked out up until that point
is it to say that that couldn't have
been thought of on this side on the side
of the reason not necessarily but it
hadn't been so you know for instance
when
john
says that god is love
that's different than aristotle saying
god is the unmoved mover
that's adding something new
is it impossible that the
the pagans couldn't have discovered that
sort of thing it's not impossible
they might have reasoned their way to it
or
um
god is an economy of persons a
relationship
there were even distinctively christian
doctrines is that impossible
on this side not necessarily impossible
but it just didn't happen that way and
the great religious traditions say what
actually did take place is god revealed
something in time is going to be a very
important thing in time
to human beings
in this way and here's what god revealed
now how does god reveal that's a key
question
some religious people
present it
as if
god sort of just
throws it down on the table and says
here's the truth shut up
read it memorize it start living
according to it that's it
or you know god gave some sort of
articulated system of truths and then
sort of put it in somebody's hands
i i guess i imagine that some
some uh very you know
strange catholics imagine that god did
that for thomas aquinas but if you read
thomas coins there's nothing remotely
like that
in there
the idea over here would be that god
would expose revelation he has something
like
information
just bits of things that you can throw
out there and they they apply to us
but they don't really touch our heart
they don't really
change us
they add something to our head
but they don't grip us where we are you
might say in our heart and in our guts
and in you know
our action
and notice these two ways of looking at
education
are really analogs of each other aren't
they
they're mistaken ways of understanding
this
over here
again it's that
human existential aspect
what does god actually mean to me
in my life as a human being
that's a that's an important question i
mean if you're actually going to be a
religious believer
you probably want to be obsessed with
that question
you you know that's part of what it
means to be religious not just to have a
whole bunch of things crammed in your
head that somebody said god you know
told to somebody at one time or another
but something that you can actually
experience something that you can have
an
existential experiential relational
connection with and live out and sort of
explore
and build upon and
develop an understanding
more and more perhaps not entirely uh
reaching the end point but more and more
comprehensive as you go through
something that you can add to something
that you can revise
something that involves a knowledge not
only of what is god but of knowledge of
what am i
and so that's what um
that's what uh about socrates that's
what kierkegaard thinks is going on with
the teacher as he's talking about it
so let's uh let's see how he gets there
he starts out talking about scientists
and about the problem of knowledge
he actually brings up this this famous
paradox that comes from the meno
how can we
um
pursue the thing the knowledge of the
thing that we want if we don't know what
it actually is
if we know the thing we don't actually
need to go look for more knowledge on it
because we already know it if we don't
know it and we want to have knowledge
about it we don't even know what we're
looking for that's a paradox and
socrates has a way of getting out of it
like he says a man knows what he cannot
seek since he knows it and what he does
not know he cannot seek since he does
not even know for what to seek
socrates thinks the difficulty through
in the doctrine of recollection
this is how he gets out of it in the
media
knowledge
is
recollection which means that
the knowledge is in fact available
within us
it just has to be brought out so this is
why socrates is
a
midwife
he
helps others bring
to birth the knowledge which they
already possess within themselves but
simply have not been able to make
accessible they don't realize that they
know
and this works fairly well for some
examples maybe not so well for other
examples but you get the general idea
if this is the case
then socrates
as kierkegaard says
cannot claim to be doing anything
um
for which he should be
honored for which he should be
remunerated
because all all he's actually doing is
bringing out of the other person what is
in that other person now it requires the
other person to actually make a
commitment
if you're a jerk
socrates can't do anything with you
if you're egotistical
if you're committed to pursuing other
goods than knowledge
or
other goods then
being a good person you know living a
moral life
like say reputation
or power
or
money
then socrates can't do much with you but
if you're willing to put yourself
in the dialectic i almost said in
socrates hands but really it's in the
dialectic that takes place between him
and the other person or the other people
then he can do something for you
what happens then is you have a teacher
and the teacher and the learner
are really on the same level
and you can pass things up the teacher
is actually learning from the learner um
kierkegaard says but the learner
eventually can become a teacher in their
own time and it can go on and on and on
and on
so if this is the case
like he says
it doesn't really matter historically
who teaches you
and time
is not
an issue in in a sense
time
is not an issue in the sense that
no single moment really
has any significance
greater than other moments this is
something that that
kierkegaard is very interested in
he says for example with his
understanding of what it means to learn
the truth the fact that i've been
instructed by socrates or by prodigals
or by a servant girl can concern me only
historically
or in so far as i am plato and
sentimental enthusiasm it may concern me
poetically
but it doesn't really matter who teaches
me
nor can it interest me otherwise that
historically that socrates or chronicles
doctrine is this or that
for the truth which on which the truth
in which i rest was within me and came
to light through myself
the learner has the truth within them
the learner is active in in socratic
education
socrates just helps to guide here and
there to you know remove
a few obstacles to
pose the right questions
like it says even in the lower world
socrates propose merely to ask questions
now
kierkegaard says if things are to be
otherwise the moment in time must have a
decisive significance so that i will
never be able to forget it either in
time or eternity
are there things about our life are
there places where
something changes for us
and it had to be that moment
is that moment precious
from a socratic perspective no
um
this is a really key point
the education could have happened at any
time it just happened to happen at this
time historically as he says you know if
i learned
about socrates and the doctrine of
recollection when i was 19 years old it
could have been when i was 28 it could
have been
98 it doesn't make any difference
but for a different kind of
self-knowledge and knowledge of the
world and knowledge of what a human
being is and how we're related to others
and knowledge about
god and our own limitations
it does matter
when we learn and it does matter how we
learn it so he says let's begin with the
socratic difficulty about seeking the
truth which seems equally impossible
whether we have it or don't have it
socratic thought really abolishes this
disjunction because every human being is
in possession of the truth
so what does this mean
about time well let's let's do a little
racing here
and this is a timeline from
birth on
and i've always had the knowledge within
me that knowledge has been there the
whole time
when i finally realized that now i have
the truth being active and before that i
was in
error
i just didn't realize that i had the
truth within me i didn't know what the
truth was
um and i also didn't realize that i had
it within me to bring out
you know why can we say that well if i
actually did know that i had it within
me sort of like going to the cupboard
you know
if i say
well
i don't have any graham crackers so i
can't make a crust for a cheesecake
but it turns out that i actually do have
graham crackers in the
cupboard or pantry or closet or whatever
you want to call it
i was just an heir i had it and as soon
as i find out that oh you actually do
have the graham crackers i get cracking
and i make cheesecake um
that's the way socrates conceives a
thing that's the way socrates has to
so he says if the teacher serves as an
occasion by which
by means of which the learner is
reminded he cannot help the learner to
recall that he really knows the truth
for the learners in a state of error
what the teacher can't give him occasion
to remember is that he's in error
but in this consciousness the learner is
excluded from the truth even more
decisively than before
and this man of the teacher thrusts the
learner away from him precisely by
serving as a reminder
only that the learner and thus being
thrust back on himself does not discover
that he knew the truth already but
discovers his
the teacher is merely an occasion for
merely an occasion whoever he may be
even if he's a god
my own error is something i can discover
only by myself
since it is only when i have discovered
it that it is discovered
you can actually have people in class
and teach them about things which they
have mistaken view on over and over and
over again
unless it actually clicks for them and
they say
oh god i've been doing that
why was i doing that i i now i
understand this is a better thing to do
until you have that moment where it
becomes a truth
for them subjectively
it doesn't matter how much objective
truth you throw at them
until something
occurs for them existentially there may
be certain kinds of truths that that
remain inaccessible so there may be
certain experiences that we need to have
in order to understand certain kinds of
truth given this this model
but it's still coming from within
ourselves
it's still coming ultimately from
ourselves it's something that we in a
way have a possession of we're just not
using that possession
now he says if the learners to acquire
the truth the teacher must bring it to
him and not only so he must give him the
condition necessary for understanding it
and that's part of what education is as
well
the condition for understanding the
truth is like the capacity to inquire
for it
but one who gives the learner not only
the truth but also the condition for
understanding it is more than a teacher
are there things within us
this is where the dramatic shift is
taking place
are there some things within us
are there some
matters about which we can't really have
knowledge
without somebody else
intervening or can we just like you know
socrates says
pull it out of ourselves because the
truth has been there the whole time
are there some things
where
we need somebody else to
make a difference
that's where we're going to move to a
different paradigm
the learner sometimes has to be
transformed he says
all instruction depends on the presence
in the last analysis of this condition
for understanding any sense
if this is lacking no teacher can do
anything for otherwise you would find it
necessary not only to transform the
learner but to recreate him before
beginning to teach him
but this is something no human being can
do
if it is to be done it must be done
by the god himself
insofar as the learner exists he is
already created and hence god must have
endowed him with the condition for
understanding the truth
for otherwise his earlier existence must
have been merely brutish and the teacher
who gave him the truth and with it the
condition
was the original creator of his human
nature what he's saying there is look
if we didn't already have
the the
condition for understanding the truth
then while we were in error we were just
sort of at an animal level and we became
distinctively human at the point
once we actually learned the jerusalem
move on with it
he says but in so far as the moment is
to have decisive significance
and once we assume this we remain at the
socratic standpoint
the learner is destitute of this
condition
and must therefore have been deprived of
it
this deprivation where could that have
come from
how is it that we were in error
did god do it
did god set up human beings
with truth inside of them and then sort
of scramble them up and say all right
now let the games begin
he says you know i can't have been that
that would be a contradiction
nor could it be an accident
this is an interesting argument here
for it would be a contradiction to
assume that the lower could overcome the
higher
it must be therefore
due to who
to himself
the human being
is
deprived of the truth
in part because of what the human being
has done with itself
on its own account
says
if he could have lost the condition in
such a way that the loss was not due to
himself and if he could remain in the
state of deprivation without his own
responsibility
it would follow his earlier possession
of this condition condition for knowing
the truth was accidental
but this is an essential condition that
can't be the case
error then and this is a new way of
understanding error error is not just
not having the truth
error is not only outside of the truth
but polemic
in the attitude towards an error combats
with the truth error resists the truth
error
hinders the truth
error wants to generate error
is very different than seeing error just
as ignorance
as not actually possessing the truth
and that those those
things that we're talking about here
they reside within the person
you know when a person is for example
stubborn
that's very different than being
ignorant
it's easier to cure ignorance than it is
to cure stubbornness isn't it
ignorance you can inform somebody that's
what socrates is doing in a roundabout
way
stubbornness you actually have to work
on the moral condition of the person
so he says
the teacher then is god the god himself
who in acting as an occasion prompts the
learner to recall that he's an error
god intervenes in some way or another
maybe not in a completely explicit way
but god helps the person learn
about his own condition
that the person is in error
that there's not just
a lack of information but that there's
something screwed up within the person
that is perpetuating this lack of
information you might say
this state this being an error by reason
of one's own guilt what shall we call it
and hear what we see for the first time
is kierkegaard is exploring certain
traditional theological categories but
he's exploring them from a philosophical
perspective again
you don't need to be committed to
christianity to understand what he's
actually saying here because he's
proceeding as a philosopher trying to
make sense out of
a christian doctrine
so he says
to go back to this
this state the being in here by reason
of one's own guilt what shall we call it
let us call it sin
so
what's going on here now
error is
sin
these are
perpetuating each other
um the teacher then is god and he gives
the learner the requisite condition and
the truth what shall we call such a
teacher how are we going to change
things here who is actually intervening
at this moment and revealing to the
person
what their condition is is it just the
teacher
so surely we agree that we've already
transcended the ordinary functions of
the teacher
insofar as the learner is an error
but in consequence of his own act he
might seem to be free
for to be what one is by one's own act
is freedom and yet to be an error is to
be unfree there's a paradox here
the person is free
right because they actually
are an error by consequence of their own
end but they're also in a certain sense
bound and exiled he said to be free from
the truth is to be exiled from the truth
to be exiled by one's own self is to be
bound
since he's bound by himself may he not
lose his bonds well that's part of the
problem there
here we get into a really interesting
issue
if it's just a matter of cultivating
something that's within us and sort of
stripping away
the detritus and
the calcs and all the things that have
overlaying it
socrates can do that
if it's a matter of
doing essentially what in our century we
call self-help socrates can do that as
well
if on the other hand
the problem goes deeper
and it has to do with a way in which our
own nature and our minds and our hearts
and our wills have become in certain
respects misformed
badly ordered
to the extent that they actually affect
our knowledge of that condition our
understanding of that condition
so that we remain in this loop where you
know because i'm screwed up
i do screwed up things and i'll screwed
up things make me feel worse and
actually make me worse and then i do
more screwed up things when it comes to
the order of knowledge
that can become a dynamic and if that's
the dynamic that's taking place one is
unfree
you can't get yourself out of that you
can't just think yourself out of that
when you realize how screwed up you are
this is saying
you can't just say oh now i understand
now i'm going to quit being screwed up
everything will be hunky-dory from now
on just you know sweetness and light
because now i possess the truth
the truth that you possess at that point
is oh
i'm really screwed up
i've really screwed things up
i don't even know if i can get myself
back to where i want to be
i'm not sure if i can trust anything
about myself
what am i going to do
that's that's an existential moment
so he says
suppose the man or the woman wills their
freedom in that case by willing to be
free they could buy themselves become
free
is this the way it works
no
you have the freedom
to
screw yourself up by making choices by
buying into all sorts of things by the
time that you realize that you have that
choice
it's usually already been spent on
something else he's got these great
examples here in a footnote he says
let's consider the point he says suppose
a child had been presented with a little
sum of money
and could buy within either a good book
for example or a toy so two choices
good book or toy
both at the same price if he buys the
toy can he then buy the book for the
same money but how can he do that he
spent the money right
so he made a choice and we do this sort
of thing all the time choices that we
make do i pursue this or do i pursue
this because i can't have handle both at
the same time
if he buys the toy
can he buy the book for the same money
no because the money has been spent
maybe he goes to the bookseller and he
says hey let's swap
i've got this uh toy
and the toy is worth x amount and the
book is there is worth x amount let's
just swap and then the book certainly
says i don't think so
you see
that toy was worth something when you
bought it but now it's not worth
anything
i'm not trading for that
so the toy is a peculiar kind of thing
once it's bought it loses all value
he says there was a time when man could
have bought either freedom or bondage at
the same price
this price being the soul's free choice
and commitment in the choice when
um
offered the choice to do the right thing
or the wrong thing that's a free choice
right
doing the right thing
has good consequences and those good
consequences aren't just the external
things it has to do with the nature of
the person and their freedom
doing the wrong thing results in
unfreedom it uses freedom and then it
sort of throws it away and you can't
just get it back here's another example
too it says suppose two opposing armies
drawn up in the field the night arrives
when both the armies invite to fight on
their side he makes his choices
vanquished and has taken prisoner
as prisoners brought before the victor
to whom he foolishly presumes to offer
his services on the same terms as were
extended to him before the battle
and the victor says
you're now my prisoner
there was a time where you could have
chosen differently you could have been
on my side not on that side
but now you're my prisoner so you don't
get to make terms you don't get to call
prices you don't get to make any sort of
swap
i call the deal now
because you used your freedom before
what that means
is that
moments in time
have decisive significance
so you have here again
drawing philosophical implications
out of a kind of theological
understanding of things something that's
coming from christian theology
moments in time matter as far as our
being in error or being in sin
because we can actually screw things up
for ourselves by the way that we use
freedom so that we not only make
ourselves unfree we actually cast
ourselves into error we actually make
ourselves less able to understand our
own condition
more in a position where we fight
against the truth where we don't want to
accept the truth even when it's being
offered to us
so what could fix that
well here we come to another
moment of significance he says
the human being can't set the human
being free
and so it is in very truth for he forges
the chains of his bondage with the
strength of his freedom
unless his bonds grow strong and all his
powers unite to make him the slave of
sin this condition of being
in error and wanting at least a certain
part of yourself to remain in here and
when the truth is offered to to reject
it to fight against it
so what would we call such a teacher
the one who restores the lost condition
who doesn't just supply information
but it changes the person
what do we call one who restores the
lost condition and gives the learner the
truth he says let us call him savior for
he saves the learner from his bondage in
front of himself let us call him
redeemer for he redeems the learner from
the captivity
in which he is and let's call
what he does in atonement
says when the teacher gives the learner
the condition for being able to
accept the truth and understand the
truth he constitutes himself in
atonement taking away the wrath and
pending upon that of which the learner
learners made himself guilty he takes
away
the effects of that
such a teacher the learner will never be
able to forget this is very different
than socrates isn't it
this kind of
teacher remember with socrates it didn't
actually have to be socrates it could
just as well be you know and be
uh you know sitting on the porch you
know communicating with you or it could
be a fortune cookie that you know sparks
the truth inside of you and gets you
thinking because the truth is inside of
you right
with this
the truth is actually
coming and the condition for being able
to understand and accept the truth is
coming through an involvement with the
divine
that sort of teacher
will not be able to be forgotten from
the moment that one forgets him he sinks
back into himself falling back into the
state
of
error so that means that this moment
becomes of radical significance
are you going to fall back in here
that's what we call backsliding right or
are you going to keep on moving forward
so he says and now the moment
such a moment has a peculiar character
it is brief and temporal indeed like
every other moment it's transient as all
moments are it's past
like every moment in the next moment and
yet it is decisive and i love this this
phrase
and filled with the eternal
such a moment want to have a distinctive
name again
forming a
philosophical category from the
theological category let us call it the
fullness of time
then he starts talking about how this
affects the the person
it looks like this is going to be the
last thing that we're going to have time
to get to in this talk
this lecture
so when the disciple is in a state of ar
he says
but is nonetheless a human being and now
receives the condition
and the truth the condition for
accepting the truth
having this removed means not just
having ignorance removed but having what
it is within oneself that is resisting
the truth removed
and being given the truth at the same
time
he does not become a human being for the
first time kierkegaard says you've been
a human being the entire time he's
claiming since he was a man already but
he becomes another man not in the
frivolous sense of becoming another
individual the same quality
but in the sense of becoming a man of
different quality or as we may call him
a new creature
so
once again
what's taking place here is a
philosopher is trying to understand
what it is that christians keep talking
about when they talk about being born
again
or being remade being
created and recreated and saying hands
insofar as he was in error
he was constantly in the act of
departing from the truth because error
and truth
are not simply
they're not simply opposites
they're opposed to each other they're
opponents
they're not just opposites they're
opponents they worry against each other
you might say
so long as he
was in error
he was constantly active departing from
the truth in consequence of receiving
the condition in the moment
the course of his life has been given an
opposite direction so a different
orientation of the person
takes place at this fundamental critical
moment
the person is reoriented
they're
maybe not you know every single part of
them you know there's work left for them
to do but something fundamental changes
there's a shift there's there's a
movement away from what kept them from
being able to take on the truth
so what do we call this
well
there's a word out there for this
already
conversion
now this is really interesting
how does kierkegaard understand
conversion is conversion something where
we say to ourselves oh now i get it i'm
going to change my mind and i can do
that myself because i have the power all
the time
and
it's my choice and so if i you know
convert myself to this this thing over
here ought to be happy i converted to it
or if i convert myself to this this
ought to be happy because it's my choice
and i get to decide it
that's not how kierkegaard understands
conversion at all
the way he understands conversion is
something else comes in
and deals with the fact that you're
totally screwed up and unable to
actually even consider the range of
possibilities and then opens up for you
the capacity to actually
grasp what the different possibilities
are and then steers you over here and
says look this is better
do you want to take it on
or do you want to go back to this stuff
over here
that's fundamentally different
that's a gift
conversion for
kierkegaard is understood
not as the divine you know steering you
around and like radically changing you
and not giving you a choice
but as the choice itself
now that you're able to make it itself
being a gift from the divine something
new
something else happens here too and this
is really interesting and this gets to
something that that kierkegaard is great
at analyzing moves
feelings
our sentiments
how we effectively understand things and
not just cognitively
which is equally philosophical by the
way
now if we realize that this is the case
given this whole picture that we've
sketched
what sort of mood would a person have
thinking about
this process the fact that
up until this time
they've been stuck in air
they have not been able to realize what
what was going on even
they've been screwing up
they've been
rejecting the truth that's been offered
to them over and over again
and it's their own fault for doing so it
says insofar as the learner was an error
by reason of his own guilt
this conversion cannot take place
without being taken up in his
consciousness or without his becoming
aware that his former state was a
consequence of his guilt
with his consciousness he will then take
leave of his former state
he will this is part of the process of
conversion
once you actually realize the goodness
of the good you turn towards it but
so long as you keep on resisting it
because of what you've made yourself
into
you will
downplay the good you'll see it as less
good than these other things over here
with this consciousness he will take
leave of his former state but what leave
taking he says is without a sense of
sadness that you know
partying with such sweet sorrow
shakespeare said right
anytime you have to leave a portion of
yourself behind you feel like you feel
bad you feel sad
anything that matters to you that you no
longer can do
you can be nostalgic you can be you can
miss it
but the sadness is a different kind in
this case he says
the sadness in this case however is on
account of having
so long remained in his former state
once you've had some sort of conversion
like that
and you know maybe it doesn't
necessarily have to be a religious
conversion like the one that
kierkegaard was talking about
when you have a fundamental
reorientation of your person and your
desires and your drives and you know
where you're going with your life
you realize your life has been screwed
up up till this point screwed up in a
way deeper than the screw-up that it may
still be
and then you can think to yourself
oh man
they've been telling me this stuff for
10 years
i wish i would have done it back then
i'm so stupid
how could i have let so much time go by
how could i have been so blind how could
i have been so deaf
how could i have heard so many times and
just rejected it and wrote it off
and that that is a feeling of sadness
i think about that myself in my own case
here's something that's not necessarily
tied up with religion i'm a person who
struggled with anger problems
most of my life
and i would be very willing to say that
most of my life i had a vicious
disposition with respect to anger i
wouldn't say i'm a virtuous disposition
cultivated yet but i'm at least you know
further on the way towards that and
something changed for me at a decisive
moment at a number of decisive moments
and i was able to see what was you know
what was going on i was able to
understand
the effects of my anger both on myself
and on other people
and why it was a bad thing when i've
been telling myself
this is a good thing this is how i ought
to act this is how you know i had all
sorts of reasons and justifications and
they were not just a matter of not
having the right information
it was a matter of my habits it was a
matter of the
way in which my will was structured the
directions of my desires
that sort of thing
when that sort of reorientation takes
place
and you look back over all these years
and you think to yourself
god i could have
been doing so much better
that makes you say that
that is what kierkegaard calls
repentance
he says let us call such grief
repentance for what is repentance but a
kind of leave-taking
looking backward indeed yet this is
where the hope comes in in such a way as
precisely to quicken the steps towards
that which lies before
so this is actually a
good place to
to
stop this isn't everything that's in
that chapter those are the key themes
just to summarize a little bit at the
end what's being contrasted here are two
very different kinds of teaching and
learning
and they both have to do with the human
condition not just with information
one is the socratic way which
kierkegaard considers to be the highest
thing that you know human beings by
themselves are capable of the other
involves some sort of intervention of
god a rupture
a moment
that attains decisive significance in a
person's life and it involves a
different conception of error and truth
than the socratic conception
so final thought
kierkegaard
has the view
that
christianity is not just something that
one should accept because it's part of
one social you
you know and then say well everybody
believes this and that so i'm going to
believe it and then i'm going to work
out the philosophical implications of it
nor does he actually believe um
what a lot of people think he does that
you just sort of make a leap into the
beyond without ever thinking about
anything without
you know
trying to to work these things out on
your own beforehand trying to use what
we have as human reason our endowment to
fully understand things before coming to
this sort of point
what kierkegaard is articulating in the
philosophical fragments and in a number
of his other works
is a very clear conception on his part
that christianity understood not just as
a body of doctrine but as a way of life
a set of commitments
um something that affects one all the
way to the to the core of one's being
not a superficial candidate but to the
core of one's being not only a matter of
one's one's heart but also one's
intellect
all that said that christianity would in
certain respects be
a more realistic way
of understanding
something like this what is the human
condition
what am i it's not just a matter of
understanding what is god or how should
i behave towards god although that's
pretty important
it's a matter of understanding
who am i what kind of thing am i
am i on the right track am i not on the
right track
and it's realistic in the sense that it
plums the very depth of the human being
in a way that socratic philosophy
and all the other
philosophies after him
according to kierkegaard couldn't do
so
that's